well the nfl has just decreed the head
of the 2022 season all teams in the
league must hire an offensive coach who
is quote a female or a member of a
racial or ethnic minority the nfl did
not define the word female or even
defined the term racial minority since
the majority of players in the nfl are
black
but they're not the only big player in
american entertainment that has a new
set of quotas the oscar says it will
disqualify any film that doesn't have
enough quote black gay or disabled
actors by 2024 by the way if that policy
had been in effect last year it would
have disqualified the best picture
winner this year
adam corolla is a comedian and author
and lifelong resident of the state of
california where a lot of these
decisions are made
and he joins us in studio adam it's
great to see i can't come to la without
seeing you
what
put this together what are we what are
we looking at here
well it's a constant obsession in 2022
of a problem that has essentially been
solved years ago and it's hurting the
country obviously to keep talking about
this thing it's like when jaws came out
remember when jaws came out no one
wanted to go in the ocean because they
thought they were gonna yeah except for
statistically it doesn't exist that's
essentially what we're doing with racism
we just keep beating it and beating it
and beating the drum and we used to be
bring us the best and the brightest and
now it's bring us the least widest
so i mean it seems like the nfl would be
maybe one of the last places you'd want
to bring this up since it's over 65
black i don't know anyone who has a
problem with that we assume it's a
meritocracy i think it is it's why
people love sports exactly i mean the
ram my rams won the super bowl i think
you know 10 out of 11 guys on the
defensive side of the ball were black
and i assume that's because of the best
players the rams can put on the flight
that's the way i like it and i cheer
it's hard for everybody because i'm
cheering for the rams like i'm cheering
for this country well kind of a weird
industry to introduce quotas like this
and it's also super unfair to the people
because whether it's a student on the
campus of harvard or the first bi
gay lesbian
black
you know female assistant coach everyone
is looking at her she may be incredibly
qualified but people are going to think
she's only there because of this quota
system
so at what point i mean my theory in
recent weeks has been this is two nuts
too few people are benefiting from it is
gonna end like when does this revolution
burn itself out i i think we're hitting
some sort of saturation critical mass
point although i say that every four
months and then they go crazier but it's
also really insidious like you know when
the politicians get up there and they go
we need a fire captain that represents
the community that he or she is like no
you don't you need a good fire captain
right it's racist to think that he would
only help people who look like him i
mean when they get up there and they do
that scared of people who look different
than you that's insidious
that you couldn't get along in this
country if that was your mindset do you
know anyone who feels that way i mean
you've lived in this country for over 50
years bill mollusian is the only guy i
know
what a good man billboard but he's got
the best hair on tv so
i got to bring him down a peg the makeup
part says it's entirely
real adam crowell it's great to see you
still in california if you ever leave
we'll do an hour-long special on your
departure please
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight